Phillip Peyton jr. was a
turn-of-the-century real estate agent
famous for outwit his adversaries and
posting his red initials to every
building under his control he Naples
generations of black New Yorkers to
inhabit prime areas of Manhattan with
modern homes nearby parks and free from
racial violence Payton was a crusading
capitalist who believed that the free
market was the key to combating racial
segregation his approach was to make the
color line costly in 1900 the year he
entered the real estate business blacks
were relegated to a handful of
overcrowded neighborhoods with
substandard housing and plagued by
racial violence to fight that I'm making
has got to be made sooner or later Pedro
and I see no better time than now one of
his first opportunities came in 1905 on
Manhattan's Upper West Side when
according to one account to property
owners got into a dispute on an
all-white block one of them retaliated
by inviting blacks to move into her two
buildings White's fled resulting in
vacant apartments on the block
Payton saw this as a business
opportunity to buy buildings at a
discount and sway more property owners
to accept blacks as tenants
why would landlords keep their
apartments empty thereby losing much
money in rent he later wrote when
there's an applicant for it and no other
objection can be raised him other than
that he has a black face so he and the
team of investors started leasing and
buying up properties on West 99th Street
at a discount one after another
eventually every building on the block
was rented to blacks the very prejudice
which is heretofore worked against us
can be turned and used to our profit
Payton Road located in a prime area of
Manhattan that bordered Central Park
West 99th and 98th streets became home
to a black community that thrived until
the mid 1950s when the government
bulldoze these two blocks to make way
for a slum clearance project a hundred
and thirteen years after Payton first
desegregated West 99th Street the former
residents of this community still hold
annual reunions honoring the
neighborhood where they were born and
raised
Haden's use of market forces to combat
segregation had an even bigger impact a
couple miles of town known as the father
of Harlem more than any other figure he
was responsible for the formation of
what would become the cultural capital
of black America it all started on West
135th Street when according to one
account another dispute between two
building owners made it possible for
blacks to start moving in but in this
case bigoted white real estate interests
weren't gonna give in without a fight
enter the hudson realty company with a
board of directors that at one time
included the co-founder of
Bloomingdale's department store a former
US ambassador and his older brother the
company wanted to restore racial purity
on the block and in 1904 at purchased
four all-black buildings ordering
everyone living there to get out so
Payton and his investors hit back they
got titled to two buildings a few doors
down and this time told all the white
people living there to move out then
they invited the dispossessed black
tenants from up the block to take their
place Hudson Realty offered to buy
Payton out but he refused so the company
gave up and pulled out altogether within
a few years black tenants inhabited
almost every building on West 135th
raised prejudice is a luxury Aidan wrote
and like all luxuries can be made very
expensive in New York City
but his Harlem's black community grew
white property owners tried to contain
it by forming real-estate associations
governed by racial covenants their
restricted landlords from selling or
renting to Black's again payton struck
back this time by reminding landlords
that participating in racial covenants
meant foregoing potential income because
blacks typically paid more in rent as he
wrote in a 1908 ad if that colored
tenement of yours is not paying you
better than anything else you own
something is wrong with landlords
choosing profit over prejudice over time
the racial covenants unraveled in 1912
building owner Reginald shank told the
New York Times that he rented his
brownstone on a hundred and thirtieth
Street to Black's because I can get more
from Negroes than from white tenants the
same year an Aleve sold her building on
136 to a black family in violation of
the racial covenant on the grounds that
she had a right to sell to any person
she saw fit in 1913 a widowed landlord
on 137th was sued by her next-door
neighbor for welcoming blacks to her
building before the judge could issue an
injunction the neighbor dropped the case
and joined her
a hundred years since Payton's death
there no monuments honoring him or even
a plaque on his former home yet black
Harlem might not exist if it weren't for
this visionary realtor who saw that in a
free market bigots can be forced to pay
a price for their prejudice by making
the color line costly
[Music]